hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the air things
masters day three uh it's yanni pognishi
vs alexandra costanooka and um well uh
there are a lot of games and of course i
can't cover all of them uh you guys have
been requesting me to show so many of
them but i'm only one person so i have
to uh you know choose very carefully and
here i chose this one for for uh several
reasons one as uh nepo is currently
leading the tournament uh seven full
points ahead of magnus uh magnus carlsen
uh and also uh as he is playing the
king's gambit in this game and uh he
made a chessable course on the king's
gamut i have not seen the course uh but
i have seen an introduction to the
course by uh himself he says that it's a
little bit of a rusty and dusty opening
maybe even a little bit dubious but if
you know what you're doing it can be
extremely dangerous and
he says that your opponents will pay a
very costly price for underestimating
the opening so let's see how it works
out in practice here uh he is playing
against alexander who uh chooses a very
very sharp line against the king's
gambit so here we have e4 e5 and f4 nepo
goes for the king's gambit and for those
of you who have been following the
morphe saga you know that we've covered
the king's gambit quite a lot and that
there are very different ways of playing
against it uh and usually in the old
days people just accepted the gambit but
here alexander goes for d5 this is the
folk beer counter gambit and it's a very
very uh dangerous opening so you have to
know it if you play the king's gambit uh
for example e just e captures on f4 uh
is considered to be a much stronger move
by the engines but uh i for you know i
play the king's gambit quite a lot and i
always enjoy it when people just uh
capture it even though it's the
strongest continuation for black but i
hate it when someone plays the the folk
beer counter gambit i have not started a
lot i know i know a few lines you know
that can help me uh in in blitz games
but not nothing serious so here we have
e captures on d5 this is uh the main
line you have to be very careful not to
do something like f captures on e5
because then queen h4 check and it's
game over black wins on the spot uh
because what do you do if king to e2
would just pick up this pawn with check
and then you'll get checkmated very soon
or if g3 captures with check uh you
blunder a rook
so of course after d5 we have to play e
characters on d5 and now the original
idea that folk beer had when he came up
with this is that black just wants to
advance the pawn to e4 and take away the
this very natural f3 uh square from the
white knight and then it's a really
really crazy game uh paul morphy uh
achieved some brilliant victories with
black in this
particular line uh so uh you know it's
it's still deadly even uh to this date
uh but here alexander goes for e
captures on f4 it's uh
people play both e4 and e captures on f4
so uh it's it's a great um uh idea to
see what nipple has prepared so knight
f3 knight to f6 and now bishop the b5
check bishop to c4 is also very very
much playable but one thing you don't
want to do is maybe c4 this does look
like you're defending your d5 pawn but
this never really ends well for for
white just to give you an example let's
say c6 we challenge white strong center
and now if d captures on c6 knight
captures because you kind of want to
keep your pawn let's say d4 now we're
going to play bishop to b for check and
after knight to c3 even bishop to g4 and
now look at this position uh black has
all of the this development and well he
didn't really uh or rather in this case
she didn't really work all that much for
it so black would be very very happy
with this and not to mention if you uh
continue with d5 and you know abandon
your development even castles you can
even sacrifice tonight here captures and
now queen b6 and i'll look at this this
we're coming to d8 this we're coming to
uh to e8 and it's gonna be very very
hard maybe even impossible to withstand
uh all of this pressure good luck
castling that um
that white king so while while it is
possible to play c4 if you don't know
exactly what you're doing maybe just you
know don't do it so bishop b5 check we
have c6 d captures in c6 knight captures
and c6 and now knight to c3 we have
bishop to d6 and now not castling but
first queen the e2 with check checking
to see if um
maybe alexander wants to go uh queen to
e7 uh and maybe trade queens or uh will
we see something else so here we have
bishop to e6 and now knight to d4 uh
very aggressive going after the knight
here it's attacked twice but also going
after the bishop on e6 the bishop is
also attacked twice and while you could
just play queen to d7 and add another
defender to both the knight and the
bishop uh alexandra just castles here
and this is where things get very very
interesting so nepal goes for knight
captures on e6 even though it could be a
little bit dangerous you can see that
nepal still hasn't castled his king on
move 10 which is very odd uh in the
king's gambit it's not odd in the king's
gambit to have your king on f1 or on f2
maybe even g2 or or you know wherever
but it's a little bit weird to have it
on an e1 square on move 10 and also
white still didn't play d4 so you
usually want to play d4 and recapture
here on f4 but now uh this is the
position and now what can alexander play
uh the queen is hanging the rook is
hanging well queen to a5 uh really
really exotic stuff here putting
pressure on the bishop
preparing rook to
rook 8 to e8 as the queen and king are
still on the same
on the same uh file so here we have
knight captures on g7 if you go for
knight captures and i fade in the other
rook just goes here and we pick up the
queen so here nipple first plays knight
captures on g7 uh keeps an eye on this
square and now we have king captures on
g7 you could also uh just attack the
queen uh instead with for example rook
f38 and then we see the the line knight
captures rook captures queen captures
knight captures uh white has to give up
the queen but the the compensation is
definitely there for example bishop
captures b captures uh white castle's
king side and we get the disposition uh
where should be uh roughly equal but
nipple would have two rooks for a queen
and also he is up a pawn so two works
for the queen he is up upon and his pawn
structure is much better he has two pawn
islands with
nothing ruined whereas alexander would
have four pawn islands uh and not not
just that also a double death pawn so uh
if anyone is to be preferred here is
white uh but uh you know it's it's it's
hard to make an assessment here so here
after knight captures on g7 alexander
first goes for king captures and g7 now
preparing rook 8 to e8 and now bishop
captures in c6 uh
making another capture ruining black
spawn structure while keeping an eye on
the e8 square but now
you really have to play a rook ft8 or
rook 888 you have to place a rook here
and we'll just uh give up
the rooks for the queen and that's it
play this position knight captures uh
we're going to castle king side and
again it's the the exact same position
that we discussed uh only
well the exact same position so here
after b captures on c6 alexander did not
go for rook 88 or rook ft8 she played b
captures on c6 but now it's a little bit
different now nipple just castles king
side and now you have this position
where it's similar to what we discussed
uh you know uh
regarding the pawn structure however the
queens are still on the board and the
black has both rooks but the problem is
uh look at
the position of the black king it's just
not all that safe and it's not easy to
attack the white king here we have rook
88 attacking the king now comes queen to
f3 and now this is a weak pawn this is a
weak pawn this is a weak pawn this is a
weak king uh how do you play here knight
to h5
uh and now comes d4 finally uh nipple
executes this d4 move but okay you will
not be capturing on f4 the bishop and
knight are covering that we have queen
to f5 now uh bringing the queen where
the action is and now there are many
ways for nepal to play this but he goes
for the absolute simplest idea g4 and
you have to be careful when playing a
move like this because if it doesn't win
you the game then you will maybe have
overexposed your king but here
it of course works so uh how do you
defend the queen g6 we pinned the pawn
king to h1 maybe king h1 could have been
played a little bit sooner so you don't
have to worry about it in the future but
uh you know this also works uh knight to
f6 attacking the g4 pawn but not just
bishop captures on f4 we have bishop
captures queen captures and now what do
you play uh well it's a it's a really
bad position for for black
the absolute best idea would be
something like knight to d5 attacking
the queen and the knight and if we have
a trade here then why just play c3 and
look at this position white is up two
pawns uh it's uh
black has really nothing to to show for
the pawn even if you go for something
like rook to e4 and win this pawn
it's just not enough rook queen f3 we're
going to pick up this pawn and if rook
captures on g4 it even loses by a tactic
rook to g1 now black has no moves if you
capture here we capture here and then
black loses the queen or if you defend
h3 we force black to capture and then we
uh pick up the queen or if black doesn't
capture on g1 we can simply pick up the
rook on g4 uh but alexander played
knight captures on g4 and here nepal
just played h3 and he was in this
position on move 20 that alexander
castillo resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so uh very
exciting game uh 20 moves uh king's
gambit in in 2022 uh very nicely done uh
as nepo said it's uh it might be a rusty
and the dusty and a little bit dubious
but if your opponent doesn't uh you know
know the
all the secrets and all the poisons that
the the position holds it could get very
very dangerous so alexander did
everything perfectly uh well uh but
at that point she had to capture the
queen she had to give up the rooks for
the queen and then it would be
okay but probably still better for white
but definitely playable i mean uh you
have the queen you have a game uh so
they say uh but the this way didn't work
so now the knight is attacked there's no
way to
play it if you move the knight then of
course the rook is coming to g1 this is
a game over and even if you try some
tricks like h5 maybe trying to open up
the h file it doesn't really matter for
example captures captures uh
there's just not enough time for black
uh to make use of this we can even play
king g1 and
well black is just too slow white will
just bring the rook into the game and
well it will be easily winning so of
course after h3 she resigned and a very
nice victory for nipple who is currently
leading the tournament in uh none other
than the king's gambit and as we haven't
shown the standings yet these are the
standings after the first three days so
today is the final day of the
preliminary so we will have three more
games nipple leading the tournament with
27 points so uh seven points ahead of uh
uh there's a three-way tie uh ahead of
magnus carlsen blaisdell artemis and
vincent keimer then with 19 points and
each geary and eric hanson
with 18 points we have another rebecca
of andreas pence
with 17 points uh levon arunyan with 15.
we have la quang liam and pragananda
with 12 we have young shisht of duda
with 11 han smoke and even in chakra
mamidarov
with zero points so far uh alexandra
costa nuke um but as she said on the uh
on her twitter profile uh that's not a
problem if anything that's uh you know
only experience that will make uh future
events much much uh better and easier uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
david kimura doug reynolds even sterling
pp poopoo and richard schwartz for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
remember to always play the king's
gambit unless you have a chance to play
the evidence gambit but you know
otherwise the king's gambit is perfectly
fine see you soon